well let's get Labor's perspective on
this morning's news their Shadow
Financial secretary to the treasury
James Murray is here with me and I want
to ask you about the junior doctor
strike in a moment but first let's talk
about nurses because today the members
of the nursing unions the results of the
ballot on the government's payoffer will
be announced are you hopeful that nurses
would have voted to accept it
well I think we all want to see an end
to strike action uh taken by nurses by
other workers in the NHS and actually
across all the different sectors of the
economy where we've seen industrial
action uh you know in recent months you
know no one wants strikes to go ahead
and I think what we always know is that
people who go on strike don't want to go
on strike they want to avoid them as
well and so I very much hope that strike
action doesn't proceed well yes but but
do you want the nurses to accept the
government's offer well that's up to
them to vote in whether they accept the
offer or not you know I think what we've
said throughout all of the industrial
disputes we've seen and is that the
government needs to negotiate with trade
unions with workers Representatives try
and avoid strike action going ahead by
coming up with a deal and a compromise
to make sure that the public have the
services that they need well according
to the Times newspaper the RCN Union the
Royal College of Nursing
looks likely to reject the government's
offer if that were the case and we don't
know the result of that ballot yet but
if that were the case would you like the
government to reopen talks well let's
see what happens and the results of that
ballot but what we said throughout the
dispute uh with the the nurses pay and
also in terms of all the other sectors
of the economy where industrial action
has happened or is threatened is that
the government needs to be ready to
negotiate you know this is this is about
negotiation this is about sitting down
around the table neither side get
exactly what they want there has to be a
compromise there has to be a deal but
it's in the Public's interest as well as
the interest of the work is concerned to
get a deal and to avoid strikes going
ahead so if the nurses were to reject
the deal you're saying that the
government should be open to to
negotiate again I mean the risk of that
potentially is it sends out a message to
other striking workers if you reject a
government's deal then the government
will come back and perhaps offer you a
little bit more well let's see what
happens um with the nurses deal let's
see what the ballot outcome is in that I
think what the important point is
generally and as a applies to all
sectors and all strikes which are
proposed or which are which are
threatened the government has to
negotiate and I think the you know if
you look at what's happening with the
junior doctors as well the other uh you
know strike which was very topical this
week and the government are not
negotiating and it feels like they
haven't really learned from what
happened with nurses by not negotiating
with Junior doctors well on on the BM
the bmas strike the junior doctors
strike they are suggesting that the
conciliation service acas gets involved
the government though says that it wants
the strikes called off first and also
the the BMA reduce its opening offer of
a 35 pay rise it's opening demand do you
think they're reasonable in those
caveats well I think we all know that
when uh when demands are initially made
by uh representatives of employees by
trade unions they are a starting point
for the employee representatives and
everyone expects there to be a
negotiation and a compromise you know
and that's what we would want to see in
all industrial disputes you know the
government sitting down around the table
having that negotiation uh trying to get
a deal struck so that we can avoid
industrial action and going ahead and
that's what we'd want to see in the
junior doctors dispute as with all other
parts of the economy
the chancellor Jeremy Hahn said it would
be a terrible mistake to give a pay rise
is above the rate of inflation he says
that wage increases that fuel inflation
would have a damaging impact on the UK
economy do you agree with that
fundamental principle that above
inflation pay deals are damaging to the
economy well like as I've said and my
colleagues have said throughout all of
the industrial disputes we've seen um
it's not for me or any other politician
to sit here
um on on TV and pluck a number out of
thin air about what people are talking
about
inflation deals that is the that is the
right subject for the negotiations to
focus on about what is a fair what is an
affordable uh pay deal to be struck and
what is Affordable for the public person
as well as making sure other people get
offended we do not have a view on it
could be to the economy if very large
pay Rises are given out well as I say
I'm really not going to get drawn on
specific numbers here about I'm not
asking for specific numbers I'm talking
about general principles there are lots
of details about the negotiation about
over what time period and about what
deal it's come up with and so on so that
is rightly uh the uh the focus of the
negotiations between the employee
representatives and the employer and the
government has a role to play when it
comes to public services and making sure
that those deals are found and to avoid
the damage that strikes cause and what
kind of damage do strikes cause how
worried are you in the case of the
junior doctor strike about patient
safety well look we don't want drugs to
go ahead
um we think the strikes um you know they
are damaging uh to patients they are
damaging to the NHS and they're damaging
to the workers themselves to the junior
doctors because everyone loses when
strikes go ahead and that's why it's so
important to make sure the government
does everything it can to get around the
table to make sure those negotiations
are happening and to avoid all the
impacts that strikes cause on the
employees themselves but also on the
wider public and patients who will be
affected by the impact of the strikes
the ons has published figures that
they're reported by the telegraph today
that say that in the week of the last
Junior doctor strike in March and the
week after that
um excess deaths were 11.1 percent above
average do you think the strikes could
be a contributing factor how much of a
concern is there about patient safety
and all this you've got to think without
speculating on individual statistics you
know I think there is clearly an impact
on patients when strikes go ahead but
there's an impact on patients of the
situation the NHS is in more widely and
the fact that the NHS Workforce has not
been invested in for many years you know
so what we said from the labor party is
that we would abolish the non-dom tax
status which is the tax status which
means wealthy people who have money
overseas avoid paying their fair share
of tax and use some of that money for
the biggest NHS Workforce investment
plan in a generation now that's the kind
of change that we need in the NHS to
make sure they've got the workforce to
try and tackle the backlogs and make
sure the patients can get treated and
that would really transform the State of
the State of the NHS
um I wonder if you could give us your
view as well on one of the other stories
our top story today the the arrest of a
young U.S Airman
um in connection with the league of
classified U.S military intelligence do
you trust that the U.S security agencies
to keep intelligence safe
well like it's obviously very concerning
uh what's being reported um I think
before we speculate on individual
details of of leaks you know as we've
seen reported on your program uh you
know the US is having an investigation
and working out what's been leaked in
all the context of it and so on so you
know let's let them get on with that
investigation but I think you know what
we need to be really clear on um is our
relationship with the us whether that's
in terms of security uh you know or the
economy uh is a critical relationship
for the UK it's a vital relationship to
be strong and it's really important to
make sure that we in the US and all of
our NATO allies continue to stand
shoulder to shoulder uh in in supporting
Ukraine okay James Murray thanks very
much indeed thank you